welcome
gentle travel
travelers
to the realm i love you
guys
what okay so get something right
[Music]
how many intersectional planes of
untethered this exists
like the ancestral plane oh just
gorgeous oh
shout out to black panther
that's so cool they said this wasn't
gonna connect right my mind is racing
with everything moon knight is doing
such cool world building i love who
she's fast oh that'd be great get bossed
in here
no
no oh no
[Music]
bro come on man he's okay come on bro
come on bro always
it's like bing bong and inside out no
don't bring that oh man
[Applause]
take it to the moon for me
take it to the moon for me mark
no take it
no way who's the one who laughs and
plays
he's [ __ ]
oh
man
[Music]
i'm steve
this sucks i can't handle this episode
this end the season
oh my god
[ __ ]
what an episode
what an episode indeed holy moly so much
to talk about whoa so welcome back to
new rock stars moon night episode 5
confirmed our theories that mark's
mental hospital is in fact the duo to
the egyptian underworld one of many mcu
afterlives alongside the ancestral plane
oh my god which also an episode that
makes us really pissed off at mark's mom
wendy but also
at least a little pissed off at his dad
yeah we'll get into that but this leaves
steven
bing-bonging into the sand of the duat
while mark watches the sun rise over a
grateful field of reeds but is stephen
gone forever
if so
god damn it
not stephen no not steven latest gaites
this is inside marvel it's our weekly
reaction show to marvel's moon night i'm
eric voss my easter egg breakdown will
be on the channel tomorrow but today i
am reacting to this episode with mt mt
thoughts impressions feelings where are
you at this episode was heavy this was
the obviously the heaviest episode of
moon knight that we've ever gotten and
huge content warning i mean obviously if
you ever seen this if you see this
episode already you already know the
deal but like man if you haven't content
warning for sure because this is gonna
get really intense
um yes hard to watch at some point i
mean not like like cringy bad this is
like dealing with some heavy issues of
child abuse of just uh triggering
psychological breaks watching a kid have
to go through and that's often the case
with people who suffered d.i.d it is a
childhood trauma so just to see this on
screen of a kid
oh i can't even like it was hard for me
to watch uh for sure it brought back
some some painful memories uh it brought
back not necessarily childhood trauma
like this but
just to see a kid have to go through any
kind of suffering it's really hard and
uh and kudos to that uh young actor who
played young mark spector uh
and kudos to marvel for going to this
place because while not everyone
watching this is tid i think people can
relate to childhood trauma in some way
and it's not something you can just bury
unfortunately yes for sure and also
shout out to ethan hawk like he's like
yeah
playing multiple characters i love how
the show allows these like allows these
actors to play different characters
because like he's just like in this like
i honestly felt like he was an actual
caring doctor i was like oh my god do i
hate you less like what's going on here
i love how like it seems like the game
is up at the end of last episode like oh
we're now in a mental hospital but
arthur harrow is still like no we're
still going to play the delusions right
i love the fact that they kept that uh
that room intact because it keeps us
guessing about the reality exactly we
think it's the underworld but it's like
is it the underworld i thought it was a
smart move to structure that inner uh
that inner reality within the inner
reality the realm within a realm that
keeps the game going just to
manifest mark's inner self-doubt uh and
to keep that jeff lemire spirit alive uh
despite the fact that we're in this
fantastical plane um all right let's
let's recap what happened this episode
so at first we uh jumped from mark and
stephen and tara white's screaming to
mark back uh well at first his mother
screaming at him just to give us a
little tease uh and we get a sense of
the cave in the opening moments um but
mark is now back in harrow's office with
fresh bruises on his face that were not
there before which i thought was
interesting we never see how he got
punched in the nose there how his nose
it looks like it was broken it was
bandaged up and it was bleeding um so
yeah just implying that there's some
other interesting element going on there
we'll talk about that um but even within
this duats realm mark still experiences
rifts in consciousness um and goes back
to this prison within a prison with
harrow and harrow suggests that even
tuaret is a delusion but when mark
brings up this boy that he's been seen
that's the moment that mark uh picks up
a sharp paperweight that we all warned
about
you don't have sharp objects like this
lying around in a mental hospital uh and
uh and he gets he gets medicated um but
i just love that we start here like we
yeah there's the screaming there's the
other past memories that we start with
but like the first real scene is this
moment where it's like no we're still
second guessing what the nature of this
reality is is it the delusions of a
mentally ill patient um
no i i think by the end of this episode
i believe that the doubt is a real thing
i think it's a smarter move to do that
but i think just the fact that the
person who manifested the nature of this
afterlife i also love the idea that
after lives are subjective and yeah
such a cool idea that they're going with
um
that in this case it's from someone
who's suffering d.i.d um like that the
nature of that afterlife is an is in a
room populated by a subjective uh
subconscious projection who continues to
make him question even that afterlife
it'd be like if um uh what's his face
eric killmonger goes back to his oakland
apartment with his dad but then in one
of the rooms in his apartment was just
some like childhood bully who says yeah
you had to beat me in hoops instead of
defending your old man in your house
like how cool would that be
why couldn't you work me faster
yeah why couldn't you ball good enough
it could have helped you
so mean
why does my mind go to this place of how
things can get meaner for the characters
i don't want that to be the case that's
probably some issue i have to work on
anyway um so we're back with tuareg and
she reveals that this realm is indeed
the underworld called the duat and one
of many mcu afterlifes she brings up the
ancestral plane of black panther which i
think is it's such a great uh touch
point for everyone watching the show
because yeah i think a lot of people
have seen black panther and that is one
of the few other times we've seen the
afterlife depicted
and just mentioning that gives us a
sense of what we're now watching the
fact that you know you've mentioned in
the past yeah we talked about here the
oakland apartment was different than the
the savannah meadow with the panther
goddesses in the tree um like i think it
is different for each person who enters
this space and i think that's really
cool like a cool way of doing it also at
least creatively um
door opening in the mcu i can't wait to
see what the afterlife looks like for
everyone right who goes through
something like that we don't we learned
that this is all on a ship that is
passing through the sands the duat uh
and the sands uh represent the permanent
afterlife and toward it plucks out their
hearts which are stone
and then she weighs them on an anubis
scale against the feather of truth i
love that this scale is as it should be
anubis not ahmed who's holding the
scales right uh and if they fall they'll
be dragged in the sands where they'll
study forever but the scales are having
trouble balancing so towards says that
they have some time to retrace their
memories to set their souls right before
they reach the end of this voyage now
inside they find the corpses of all the
terrible people that mark spectre has
killed as he worked as uh conscious
avatar as that warrior um but they also
see this boy who's not dead who's just
kind of like running around like hey
come chase me
and then um but stephen follows this kid
into the memory realizing that this boy
is mark's younger brother randall aka
rory
i don't know how you get row row from um
randall but i love the nickname railroad
and yeah
your boat am i right they're on a boat
soro
that's right well these boys walk from
what seems like an inner city alley
barbecue to a random easily floodable
death cave in the middle of a forest
despite this being
chicago are there flood caves in the
middle of chicago somewhere yeah where
were they when mrs o'leary's cow kicked
over that lantern could he used to been
extra water then
i'm getting married in in august in
chicago i have to warn my guests to look
out for the flood caves
you know this is what happens
you let your kids watch the movie
morbius because they want to become
morbius so they go into the cave and
they they one of them dies never no
electricity
sorry i've had enough play-doh to
understand allegories of caves all the
symbolic imagery of caves we see batman
there's caves there uh thor went into a
cave in age of ultron and caves again
it's just like the geography of the city
of chicago which is clearly a studio
backlot with not a whole lot of extras
it looks like this show was shot in
covent but like it is outdoors you could
have had just a couple cars going there
just made me question like is this
version of chicago meant to be depicted
as surreal because the chicago idol does
not have random forest caves that are
within walking distance that flood that
quickly and that easily in the middle of
the city i mean i would understand if
this were in like small town new
hampshire or maine if this were dairy
and these are two kids from the stephen
king universe yeah i assume they have
blood caves and dairy uh anyway i'm
overthinking this i am sorry hey man you
never heard of the shy town caves man
they're everywhere i
didn't didn't know didn't know they were
there um well roro cannot roll himself
out of that water so uh mark's mother
cruelly blames cruelly blames uh mark
for it very hard to watch all this stuff
yeah and mark and steven then arrive at
the memory of the dick site where mark
reveals his going awol led to him
getting discharged and working for his
old ceo bushman they brought in
fishman's name yeah surprise to me crazy
dude not a good guy uh when they were
working as mercenaries uh bushman led a
gig to raid a tomb where bushmen just
suddenly changed their plan midstream
killed all the witnesses including
leyla's father mark tried to help them
escape but himself got shot crawled to
conscious tomb where conscientious took
advantage of mark's state and convinced
him to let him take over mark's body as
avatar and i love that in this memory
they're even calling it out like
can't you just let the man die like what
right he's taking advantage of you
definitely be the preferred route here
like i love how that was a callback to
that um the trial episode when hathor
asked mark do you feel like you've been
you're being taken advantage of by
kanchu and we can see very clearly here
that kanchu took advantage of a dying
man which is kind of messed up i totally
did totally did um now back on the ship
tour reports that up above souls are
just plopping down prematurely damned
meaning and i love this harrow must have
totally freed ahmet from that who
shopped he's now using it to just go to
town on society
what is going on up there um but uh
tawara agrees to steer the ship around
to the gateway of osiris that they can
send a message to layla to free khanshu
to give mark some healing powers uh and
i guess bring him back from the brink of
death uh to confront hero uh but an
argument between mark and stevens just
triggers mark uh sending him back to
hero's office which leads to the dark
memory of mark's childhood bedroom where
his mother abuses him and child abuse
not easy to watch at all this was
really really tough uh and again we
talked about this tough to see anybody
get abused like that especially tough to
see a kid get abused like that um but
it's important that they show this at
least they don't i'm glad that we didn't
actually see it happen we cut to outside
the room um but we learned that this is
the trauma that led to mark's did and
this is
how did will manifest in patients uh
extreme trauma it alters are often
created as a coping mechanism to deal
with that trauma to disassociate from it
um and in this case mark so wanted to
disassociate from this woman being his
mother that concept he said this that's
not your mother that's not your mother
that doing so created this altar uh with
a fully different loving mother and what
a cathartic reveal an explanation to why
episode one opened with stephen collins
mom and signing off with the phrase
latest gaites like that is
uh
it makes me really appreciate episode
one that much more and uh and it really
explains why tuareg is their guide in
this afterlife because these guys need a
mom
for sure like to maternally take care of
them and listen to them mm-hmm
like for like in when watching um what
stephen react to like hero calling his
fake mom it was just so it broke me man
because like he at some like at some
subconscious level he knew that his mom
was dead and that that was so sad so
yeah and that's what we see there in the
next scene where stephen finally uh
accepts the truth that his mom is dead
and i think that was an important arc
for him it was hard to see him go
through that though to realize his
function like
what the reason he exists what a thing
to realize for someone who thinks that
they're a distinct human being um
without a an altar that they have to
share a body with but now they're in the
memory of mark walking away from his
mother's shiva and steven tells mark
that it was not his fault they have a
critical moment there where they can hug
it out
but at this point the ship is nearing
osiris gate their scales are still going
back and forth so those sand forms of
mark's past victims are now crawling out
of the desert to try to drag him back
into the sand stephen fights them off
impressively uh saying he loves cricket
and he sacrifices himself falling into
the dunes and steven turns into sand
and right at this moment the scales
balance and mark is transported
immediately immediately to the field of
reeds as the sun rises and that's where
we are left this episode no post-credits
scene no post-credits scene this this
week so all right hopefully next week i
don't know i don't really care if we
have post credit scenes in the show i
feel pretty good at where we're at um
but
uh what exactly happens to stephen now
is he gone forever does mark still have
d.i.d i mean if not the show is really
going to take some liberties with how
did works and we're all going to feel
really weird talking about it uh but
where does this leave that mysterious
third uh presence yes in that
sarcophagus shaking coffin but there are
a few uh cool new projects going on in
new rockstars we want to let you know
about first new rockstars is on tumblr
so find us continuing the moon night
conversation at new rockstars official
on tumblr jessica clemens is actually
over there making all kinds of fun
content
yes um second we are launching a brand
new daily live show starting next monday
may 2nd it's called the break room it's
going to be live on the new rockstars
youtube channel every weekday afternoon
you will not see mt and i every there
because this is going to be live in
person at new rockstar's burbank office
uh mt is in the uh massachusetts area
yeah i am in san francisco um so it was
decided that it would be more fun if
everyone was in the same room i agree
watching the early test screenings tommy
jessica brandon literally the funniest
people that you guys will ever meet like
go check out the break room because it's
so they cracked me up and then hopefully
sometimes empty and i may be able to pop
in on those shows um but it's it's it's
gonna be a really fun format but if you
live in the san francisco area and you
want to get a bit of extra vos uh i'm
going to start doing improv shows at the
end games theater called stage works
theater on valencia street in the
mission starting may 14th whatever the
the second saturday in may is so uh
some more details on that it's gonna be
really fun the group they they cast me
with are hilarious like you're gonna
love them so dude improv is always the
best if you want to laugh go see eric
but of course we all want to remind you
to grab yourself a moon night latest
obsession shirt from new
rockstarsmerch.com these shirts directly
support the channel and when you buy one
at nyrockstarsmerch.com you will unlock
the ability to buy in a custom shout out
that's going to run along the bottom of
these enzyme marvel after show so eric
says do you think there might be a
chance at a full-blown kang cameo before
or in the final episode um
i don't think we'll see a full-blown
kang cameo in the final episode maybe in
a post-credits scene i just don't think
we need kang in this show we already got
the the easter egg but yeah i don't
think we need kang but like i think that
we will get a kang popping up and be
like hey i'm still here come check me
out in quantum media
something like that from marvel
i mean we'll see that at some future
marvel property
just but i think the the jacket to rama
tut was enough of an easter egg just to
imply that he's part of this history for
me i'm good with that um uh kimberly
asks anubis zushapi is always centered
and illuminated in the end credits
significance um kim you might be on to
something the fact that anubis's scales
show up now in this episode to play such
an important role maybe we'll actually
meet anubis in the final episode likely
and then devin says i want leyla's
marshmallows um yeah i want them too i
yeah they look yummy who i never really
think of marshmallows it's just a random
snack food lying around they get a
little chunky if they're just sitting
out but
um yeah i like this show has made me
want to grab a i'm a big fan of
marshmallows myself so i want all
marshmallows not just layla's yes
send them to your marshmallows mts pete
man
[Laughter]
all right mt what's our uh big question
this week after episode five well eric
we gotta ask what the fish happens to
stephen now because i'm not okay i'm not
okay seeing my best friend during the
sand no it's it's hard uh so tuareg
explains earlier in the episode that if
the scales do not balance then you get
thrown overboard from the boat and the
dead will drag you down in the doo watch
where you will remain forever frozen in
sand like a real boat yes uh-huh
um so that means there are four scale
outcomes when you think about it too bad
too good so if the heart is heavier you
get thrown in the sand if the feather is
heavier you get sent to the reeds
if the scales balance perfectly good job
that's enough that's reads tie goes to
the runner um but if the scales never
balance uncertainty bad you gets into
the sand straight through so that seems
to be the stakes of what's happening in
this episode and then the final scene
with stephen he sacrifices himself while
the scales are still trying to balance
and falls into the sand and then himself
turns into a frozen sand form of himself
but uh the scales have not yet balanced
and only after that transformation
happens to the scales finally balance
now the issue with this that we should
talk about is that steven didn't really
deserve according to if it was just
anubis judging him on his own stephen
didn't get deserved to get dragged into
the sand
i mean maybe the dunes operate by a kind
of flores lava rule and just by touching
it that's enough to get bing bong um but
there's also like timing questions with
how this this kind of judgment works
because remember amit scales could judge
people's souls at any point in their
lives and be able to assess the whole of
their lives but the scales on the deck
of the ship are not ahmed scales they
are anubis scales which uh anubis is the
correct purveyor of justice according to
egyptian mythology and according to
anubis and tuaret the judgment has a
ticking clock to it she gives mark and
steven time to try to get their souls
straight and uh this seems to be
anubis's rules based on the souls
dropping from above amit though is in
control at the moment so tewara thought
souls were being judged prematurely but
mark and stephen uh might want that kind
of premature judgment rule to apply to
them in this moment because it would
give them a loophole to allow steven
perhaps to get off of that sand and join
mark in the field of reeds the problem
is i don't think mark wants to be in the
field of reeds he wants to live he wants
layla to free conscious so conscious
healing powers pop out those bullets and
then mark can fight harrow's moon knight
and the above world and based on trailer
footage i think that is going to happen
in the final episode there's going to be
some kind of loophole from the gods
tarara may be pleading mark's case to
the any ad maybe next episode and
they're able to say
uh you know ahmed sent a lot of people
to so everyone from this point forward
the moment ahmet became active again uh
you're not dead
[Laughter]
we'll see joe biden just signed an
executive order pardoning everyone from
the afterlife
i think it's possible though uh we're
forgetting we didn't see this person
this episode that third altar in the
sarcophagus i still think it's jake
locklear it's gotta be i think jake
lockley could still be present somewhere
in mark's physical body has not been
sent to the sand or to the field of
reads and is still there in the mental
hospital and i think jake could take the
wheel for the final episode as conscious
warrior the problem is it's going to
make us spend that chunk of the final
battle with a character we have not yet
met yet right we don't know what jake
lockley is like are we gonna accept a
new character just in the final uh
scenes or is it gonna feel like oh
actually you were there with us the
whole time and i am ready to see this
guy fight especially if he is a boxer
especially if that's why uh mark's nose
is broken it's maybe steven got in a
fight because that looks like a boxer
wound doesn't it and that opening scene
oh yeah for sure like that he looks like
he got decked pretty damn hard and i
hope that like you know in the comics in
the jeff lemire comics there is a lot of
like um you know
uh patient abuse on the part of these
two jerks um that worked on this mental
hospital so like i wonder if that we
were seeing the same thing here with
arrows people i forget their names
billion billion bobby is that right
bobby yeah yeah billy and bobby um
punching uh mark
yeah and i think that much was implied
right like that you know hero was like
you're starting random fights we saw
them get uh they you know medicated him
uh they sedated him and then harrow
later gaslighted mark and said oh that
never happened like so i think there's
evidence here that they are hurting
these patients and then just lying about
it well let's talk about stephen so uh
is he gone forever well i don't think
stephen is necessarily gone forever just
because those sand souls uh first off
that were attacking them were also
damned but they were still walking
around so maybe stephen could live on as
a sand person and just kind of move
around those dunes as a lava monster
dragging other people down into the pit
i don't know about that but um if mark
could get released from the field of
reeds stephen could get released from
the dunes i think that's going to be the
simple way that they approach this is
that
some of this stuff can get reversed
but the show might also be sane and this
is not me saying i want this
interpretation to be true but the show
could be saying that mark achieving
peace with the stephen alter and finally
accepting that railroad's death was not
his fault is his way of getting over his
need for the stephen alter and stephen
might disappear from his subconscious at
that point
i don't
know about that because i think the
implication might be that mark scales
might be balanced because stephen was
now finally out of the picture like
the skill's only balanced right after
steven hit the sand right right so the
implication at least based off of like
the recency bias would tell you that
that is why they balanced now i don't
know if that's the best way to show how
did works and the show has otherwise
been pretty good so far um but again
based on the rattling of that
sarcophagus there is still another alter
inside mark oscar is it confirmed that
there are more than two
so i think it's not like his did is
cured uh some and then what also we
should point out some other trauma
might have created that alter some other
trauma that we didn't see in this
episode it seemed like this episode
covered our basis of everything bad that
happened to mark but maybe something
else happened that in in some history
chapter that we didn't see yet that led
to mark creating this third altar that's
now in the sarcophagus i mean it makes
sense because like you know mark has
this really dangerous line of work and
he's a mercenary and so like i'm sure
he's going to deal with his fair share
of traumatic events so like i can see
this jake lockley persona with his altar
rather um manifesting at some point
during his very dangerous career yeah
ultimately here's what i hope for the
final episode i hope that jake uh the
jake alter is able to reconnect with
konshu and then the warrior we see fight
is really the best fighter of these
three is jake um and that ahmet over
populating the duat with
it's raining evil men uh i would hope
that that is enough of like if that
could convince tawara to turn the ship
around that might be enough to uh
convince the iniad to erase all the test
scores essentially and that this series
might end with mark and stephen and jake
all living peacefully together not
blocking each other out so i don't think
i don't want this show to say this is
how you cure d.i.d maybe get a superhero
go to the egyptian underworld like i
don't by the way i don't think the show
is saying that i think at the end of the
day all three of these altars need to
like co-exist and continue to live
uh but not block each other out i think
that's going to be the arc of the
character is that they learn to
cooperate uh and kind of co-habitate in
this space you know for sure i think
that you know the whole the idea of
balance was a core part of this episode
and like you know with and like you said
with stephen
going off of the ship and like sort of
like
taking his heart out of the out of the
equation the scales were balanced
because it's like all right the whole
idea was for you to 100 know yourself
and now that steven is now sand you
technically now 100 know yourself so
congratulations welcome to the field of
reads um so yeah i think that that is um
going to be a huge part of what
potentially gets mark out of the
afterlife or out of the field of reeds
is because we do have that sarcophagus
that is shaking um and so like if that
sarcophagus were to come out then
technically he's no longer balanced so
wherever tomorrow it is on her on her
way back they're gonna probably pop back
and be like hey i'm back because i'm no
longer fully balanced because like i
don't fully understand myself because of
this mysterious persona yeah it's torah
seemed completely caught off guard by
having to judge someone with the id like
she or script said welcome weary
traveler and she'd correct herself of
travelers i guess in this instance so
and she said it even been a while since
someone had gone through which is which
is interesting does that mean like
not like
in this case mark's afterlife takes the
form of the egyptian underworld
and by it's been a while it means that
only people who are real believers of
this form of the afterlife actually did
this version of it everyone else has
been having different afterlife like
someone had a metallica themed afterlife
someone had a
power rangers themed after like no one
has had an egyptian mythology theme i'm
gonna have a power rangers themed
afterlife it's gonna be great
but no that is a really good point
because we learned in a previous episode
that like the gods left because everyone
abandoned worship of the gods so like it
does make sense for you know torah to be
like all right no one really comes by
here because people haven't really like
dedicated their lives to egyptian
mythology like you
stephen so hey
thanks for coming by
yeah
i think ultimately uh steven is not
permanently sand uh i would be surprised
if they just left him there he's been
such a a wonderful character to spend
this time with i think this series will
end with him back in mark's body uh back
in steven's body i hope he's gonna say
who truly owns it um so and i think
there's plenty of ways the show can kind
of uh alter the rules especially right
now the reason stephen is there is
because someone really altered the rules
and
like cheating is happening left and
right uh arthur harrow using ahmed to
just plump people down in there
someone's got to make a move here i mean
i don't trust the indiana to do it but
maybe tawarah can i think tawarra will
be our champion tomorrow at working with
jake lockley they're going to be the
ones we get posters for yeah at the end
of the show i want to have an avatar on
earth because i want to see her more
yes
oh please
tour it needs to be a permanent fixture
in the mcu 100
um all right a lot of questions coming
out of this episode we'll talk about
more of them but first we want to thank
helix sleep for sponsoring this episode
even if you have magical armor that
appears out of nowhere to help you fight
crime you still need a good night's
sleep on a mattress made just for you
our friends at helix mattress are here
to make sure you have that helix sleep
is a quiz that matches your body type
and your sleep preference is a perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and burn mattresses mattress is great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers both mt and i have mattresses
and we love them we're getting great
sleep so the mattress ships right to
your door for free no need to go to a
mattress store just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get tried out
for 100 nights risk-free but they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you're gonna love it helix
is offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com inside
marvel we also want to thank upstate for
sponsoring this episode we've all been
hit by an unexpected expense or a bill
in times like that it's normal to not
know where to turn luckily upstart is
here to help upstart powered personal
loans can help you pay down high
interest debt all online with simple
easy to understand payment terms upstart
has helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date rather than
looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan check your rate in minutes
for loans between 1 000 and 50 000
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting the loan
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit your
income certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com marvel and we want to thank
masterclass for sponsoring this episode
with masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace you can learn how to
sing from christina aguilera improve
your cooking skills from thomas keller
or learn to dj from quest love with over
100 classes from a range of world-class
instructors that thing you've always
wanted to do it's closer than you think
masterclass has a ton of great courses
for film and tv nerds like us i really
enjoyed the danny elfman class and
composing elfman histonic hunt
alvin has done a ton of iconic scores
including the uh tim burton movies men
in black sam rainey spider-man one and
two spider-man no way home the upcoming
doctor strange in the multiverse madness
he talks about how he started uh he
always starts to score from one or two
of the most important moments in the
movie and then works his way out from
there there are great classes from
warner herzog helen mirren james cameron
spike lee all the master classes are
shot and edited more like tv shows
instead of boring lectures they're
engaging and easy to watch i highly
recommend you check it out get unlimited
access to every master class i highly
recommend you check it out get unlimited
access to every master class and the
inside marvel audience can get 15 off an
annual membership go to masterclass.com
marvel now that's masterclass.com marvel
for 15 off masterclass all right mt i
want to ask you what is currently
happening on the surface world is ahmed
eating everyone is there a giant
crocodile hippo lion is going around
eating souls i hope so i hope it's like
the end of the suicide squad we're just
a giant crocodile be like ah time to eat
everyone
why did you think i was a good guy
harold
just screaming the hell what is going on
it's just king k rool for the donkey
kong series
gameplay gallery he's just blasting in
the background
um but no um
but no um i think that what yeah what's
happening like in the surface must be
pretty bad because all these souls are
plopping down into this underworld this
afterlife so like you know what i think
that the implication here is that harrow
has the power the full power of amit
because he he only had a sliver before
and now he somehow accessed this full
power of i think ahmet in in quotation
marks because something fishy is going
on here especially considering that
anubis like you said is primarily on the
scales rather than ahmed like i think
that anubis or some anubis-affiliated
entity is messing with hero and wants
more dead people in the after world
um because like oh maybe he's like
lonely or like he wants more power or
something but something's going on where
hero's getting played i don't think that
ahmed is the one fully doing this i
think ahmed is the one getting blamed
for it interesting i think ahmed is true
i think ahmed's just a little stinker of
the bunch i think anubis is neutral
um that'd be an interesting take mt i
like so far i think anubis is just we've
only seen the statue of anubis doing it
um like it's arguable and maybe osiris
or the surviving members of the indiana
have been up to something um i just uh i
think as far as anubis is concerned it
really is a truly impartial judge i
would love to meet anubis next episode
to see what what they think
but yeah i mean up or upstairs it's got
to be nuts because current like in the
past arthur harrow would judge people
just with this like slow process of
using uh his cane one by one for each
person and that kane possesses just a
shred it's just it was almost like a
promise every time we saw this crocodile
heads right like it's just a pro like
it's a promise of what will be to come
when ahmet gets released
and
i think i mean what's good is it gonna
be ethan hawk writing like in the never
ending story
yeah eat them
that one's evil eat them
like boba fett riding the rancor at the
end of the day
hero wins
[Applause]
well like all of his followers that love
to be like heroic what are you doing
it's like i gotcha
kill them next
i mean if not that it's what is going on
he's just like having people who they
thought were evil line up in in train
stations and like okay you next oh okay
now you know they were getting people
fast the rate at people falling from the
sky into the duat was pretty quick they
were making
short work of uh sending all those
people to the underworld so i'm just
saying yeah there's some crazy [ __ ]
happening terrible things happening
maybe mark wants to stay dead because i
don't want to go back to that it looks
very scary
hey it's like when the volunteers enter
the swamp are you friend you hear me
friend the gator bait
gang bang
hashtag gator bait uh but no i think
that i honestly like and you mentioned
osiris i think that osiris could
actually hold on i'm like crying because
of the laughing sword um
no i think that osiris could actually be
like behind this as well because like
we'd learned that from tararet that
osiris portal was the only one that she
could use so like i don't know something
fishy with osiris i don't know i i think
to what i think uh you're right toronto
is right i don't think osiris is the
like mastermind i think he's just like
he's no good i think the members of the
inead have done some [ __ ] um i don't
think he's like the mastermind i just
think it is ahmed i think there's enough
for me to believe that it is just ahmed
who's been uh the way that kancha
manipulated mark i think
ahmet is enough of just like
a militant threat uh an objective evil
that's doing all this
but uh let's talk about harrow's office
in the do-watch ship i thought this is
an interesting structural choice to
continue is this show ever going to give
us an objective answer on what the
reality is or is this just going to be a
theme of the show where we're always
just kind of
interpreting what reality is i think
that you know in the case of hair uh
harrow's office i think that is um
entirely a a construct because like like
we said i like toarat establish like
it's all just sort of just like all in
within mark's mind and how he manifests
the duet which is an impossible to grasp
um
concept so
i think that by episode by the finale
like it'll be definitively like all
right this is what real harrow is doing
um real harrow was definitely not a
doesn't have a phd and like this was all
made up so i think that yeah the diploma
wasn't even signed i didn't see a
university listed on that diploma it was
just like you literally printed one off
from the internet that just says hey
when your kid wasn't uh you know
independent diligent enough to get his a
college diploma you print this you print
this out you put it on you put
yeah
but yeah i i think that it's gonna be
definitively like all right this was all
within mark's mind and it was a nice
little homage to a jeff lemire's amazing
run of moon knight yeah really really
great run and i think the uh i like it
better this way
there will always be hot takes that say
everything that happened in the show was
in mark's mind and i think that that's
fair and valid to interpret it that way
especially with how moon knight comics
are i think in this case in this show
everything that happened on the show
including the duo
this voyage to the duo is real it
happened to this character um and
uh
the point is that he is meant to doubt
it uh because that is how his mental
illness makes him interpret this world
right um
i just think it's cool i thought this
was really well done i think this
episode last episode this whole series
has been really really this episode is
my favorite episode of the bunch so far
because like just because of the
emotional impact it had it was so good
and i'll say that like it's so well done
that unlike some of the other disney
plus shows going into the finale i'm
good like i don't i don't need some big
cameo to happen i don't need some big
revelation to happen i feel like i know
what i need to know and i'm good like
uh like i don't need
any kind of big twist or connection to
anything it's it's answered all my
questions at this point and now i just
need to see it resolved which i think is
where you should be heading into a
finale yeah random like questions like
do you think ahmet like if she is real
will take the form of mark's mother like
sort of like to have this like
that would be crazy i would love that if
he just got a chance just be like hey
mom you're the worst pop um even though
don't punch women and don't punch your
mom but like
you know if it was a god impersonating
your mom
and the god was evil feel free to punch
your fake mom now you're really talking
about suicide squad right now where
polka dot man sees uh
i don't think we're gonna be looking at
that i don't think they're gonna have
this woman come back and like uh
savagely kill lots of people and that's
gonna be the former mom it takes but i
could see maybe mark having to
reconfront uh some vision of his mother
again because she is in that mental
hospital which i just think is such a
cruel thing for a trauma victim to have
to go through like you'd think that that
person dying would just be the end of it
but no to have to see their spectral
presence her last name is spectre just
like yours is yeah yeah yeah um but
speaking of that mental hospital the
third altar in the sarcophagus if we
assume it is another altar in there um
what trauma in mark's life or even
stephen's life do you think could have
created if that is the jake lockley
altar
what led to that creation what could it
have been stephen and mark didn't really
realize that jake is there but steven
might have created that altar i love the
idea that stephen created this altar
because like it sort of inferred that
this altar tends to come out when you
know stephen and mark are in the most
danger like this seems to be like the
the defense sort of um altar um we're
like you know he's not like i i wanna
like punch everyone just for fun it's
like i come out when
my host needs me the most like to to
really defend him because like i am the
one that fights the best like i am the
fighter alter and so um i think that
like i was alluding to before because
mark has this mercenary pass and because
like he has he does a lot of like
killing and dealing with people i think
that there's a stronger altar within him
that comes out during those really
intense moments of that mark gets
overwhelmed it's like all right maybe i
can't do this and jake's like don't
worry i got this like i i know how to do
this and so um yeah i think that maybe
the trauma of just like his just
terrible life of being a mercenary
probably created um this this jake
lockley alter
adults but what do you think it seemed
mark had some interesting lines about
his life as a mercenary he's like he
even seemed to uh be
forgetful of like he's like oh gabon
like he remembered right places new york
where he killed some of these people but
it seems like even he was having a
spotty memory and he had this
interesting line of the uh the healing
is a curse
like
he like the desensitization to killing
all these people was was a curse in and
of itself so it seems like yeah
absolutely might have been created in
order to help himself get through taking
all these lives um i'm just curious like
i assume jake is gonna show up what's he
is he just gonna be rocky balboa like
what is he gonna sound like
he's probably gonna have a really thick
new york accent which i hope that he
does that would be really great yeah um
because like the fact that he spent time
in new york that was confirmed he said
new york it's like okay then i assume
that's where jake was yeah like we're
definitely gonna see the new york guy
again in some type of jake lockley
flashback be like i killed you
gotcha you know
i guess mark manifested stephen uh just
in his chicago home it doesn't have to
be where you are is the voice that you
end up having that british accent was
just pulled out of you know wherever
um so i can't wait to see this final
battle i assume that sarcophagus is
literally like the bullpen like let me
out let me let me out
i got shot i don't like that
let's end this episode with just some uh
wild hot takes for the finale
predictions
um
so for the finale i'm going to come out
and say i don't think kang is going to
show up in the show um i don't think we
need kang in this show i think maybe in
a post-credits scene to reveal him as
ramadan would be fun but i don't i don't
need jonathan majors to step out and
help in this battle right now yeah i
think at the at the most we might get
like uh you know an illusion like our
statue and be like oh yeah that was a
rama touch this blah blah blah stephen's
gonna be like yeah that was him and like
he's probably coming up later in another
marvel movie um but like that's probably
the most that we'll get because like we
did get that that um symbol behind that
on that jacket so like i think that we
might get some type of illusion towards
ramatot's um influence to egyptian
society um but in terms of the finale i
think that uh polka dot man's mom is
going to be killing all these people oh
but he wakes up no i think that you know
whoever is truly behind this is has
completely
taken over or is completely just running
amok and like at this pyramid and
is just taking lives i think that like
this wherever they are is like really
not great right now like there's
probably like a a huge beam in the sky
like there is in every superhero movie
it just be like all right here comes
death and so mark and layla because this
is the final episode this is sort of
just like all right we have to save the
day um in this tomb um and so yeah i
think that you know it's just episode
six is just gonna be them
just stopping on it entirely
i mean can we just take a moment to uh
pour one out for the poor street level
folks of the mcu who have had to deal
with dusting we've had to deal with
celestial cresting who now have to deal
with a giant crocodile thing eating the
kind of bad ones eating their grandmas
like
they they've got to just be like all
right just end it just kidding seriously
if you're a therapist in the mcu you're
eating good right now you are you got
some you got business
um do we think there's going to be any
kind of multiverse mention uh any kind
of connection to multiverse amount i
mean the finale will happen as
multiverse of madness is coming out is
that timing coincidence is it just
whatever i think that there there will
be a connection to multiverse and
madness like in particular because like
when when tawarit first notices all
these souls coming down i noticed that
she says fear has taken over the real
world and i was like fear because like i
have this weird idea that like the fear
lords of the marvel comics like your
your despair all your your dark your
nightmares will factor into
um this next phase of the mcu so like i
think that maybe what we could be seeing
is that a lot of these souls could be
like from multiverse of madness like who
knows like well this could be like the
dark souls that were being killed from
the the events of doctor strange so um
you know i think it'd be very
interesting to see like that crossover
there where like all the fearlords come
back it's like ah he helped us all the
dark people from the universe come back
thank you haro you dumb idiots and uh
you just made another doorway for for
dark people to come through so i don't
know but that's just me what do you
think i think any time that you pray for
like a crazy marvel lore cameo to come
in you wanted to at least be grounded in
the themes of the show so
made or he remains made perfect sense
for loki this is a show about timelines
it's a show about destiny it's a show
about fate uh and kang is the perfect
embodiment of those themes right so with
this show the show is so much about like
you know uh morality and
identity and uh the judgment of one's
soul like every episode is touched on
that theme this episode is uh central
about that balance so the fact that this
doctor strange promo just came out
showing the living tribunal showing up
in multiverse madness like
and the the living tribunal showed up in
another form in the void in loki i think
it could be cool to just imply that
there is some kind of cosmic hierarchy
to the legal structure in the mcu that
the india ad is responsible to the
living tribunal in some way
so i assume that some part of the finale
is going to deal with uh tuareg osiris
debating in the indiana floor so it'd be
great if there could be some implication
of there being a chief justice that they
should take this to and that answer to
that question could at least just be
presented in the background detail of
that cameo and multiverse of madness i
love the living tribunal as a cosmic
entity i've been wanting to see them
appear
in some form ever since infinity war so
uh i think this could be a a great
tie-in here bro it doesn't appear i get
it i love that idea so much because like
you're so right because they did appear
in that trailer but also the living
tribunal as an entity sort of you know i
don't want to say he has d.i.d but like
he has three faces and he has three
different personalities so i think it'd
be a great great inclusion for this show
for this try like this tributal like the
ultimate judge to be like all right
mark's all right he can leave he can
leave the after worlds he's all right
with me because like i sort of relate to
him
on a level right it could be argued that
only the living tribunal is uniquely
positioned to understand what mark is
going through um like the numbers are
there the parallels are there it'd be
cool it'd be cool to see that i would i
would just
my reach that's my reach pitch for where
i like that reach pitch a lot i like it
all right we'll leave it there for this
episode of inside marvel again our
easter egg breakdown is coming gonna
come out to the channel tomorrow not
today we need some time to digest it but
later today you will see my breakdown of
uh the living tribunal cameo in the
doctor strange footage uh there's a lot
of cool new shots from that doctor
strange promo drops so uh don't forget
to check out our many great merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow mt mastertainment
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
late escape let us get us oh man that's
a lot more sad this episode but leia's
yeah
you